-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I feel the love.
I feel like the GameStop
of late night.
I really do.
Yeah, right now,
the world has been
separated into two groups --
those who have no idea
what's going on
with the stock market
and those who have no idea
but invested anyway.
Well, guys, some news
out of Washington.
It looks like
President Biden is likely
to keep the Space Force.
Yeah. When asked why
they're keeping Space Force,
a Biden spokesperson said,
"Because it's funny."
That's right -- it looks like
Space Force is here to stay.
Apparently, Biden had
no choice after Trump signed
a 30-year lease with the moon.
Yep, Biden is keeping the
Space Force around
for a very important mission.
He's going to use them
to knock down the wall.
Biden's decision
is actually a big deal.
When they heard, the
two members of the Space Force
high-fived in their
basement cubical.
Yep, Biden is keeping
the Space Force,
but their budget
is somewhere between
the Department of
Hot Tub Regulations
and the Office of --
-[ Laughs ]
-Hey.
-You jumped on it, man.
The Department of
Hot Tub Regulations
and the Office of VCR Repairs.
So in between, in betwixt.
In betwixt the two.
It seems like there's
so much going on right now.
I mean, the stock market
is all over the place.
Netflix just announced
that "Bridgerton"
is their most-watched
series ever.
A Margaritaville Resort
is opening
in the middle of Times Square.
And there's
a Grape-Nuts shortage.
There's a lot to go over,
so let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Ding ]
First up, the stock market.
People on Reddit started buying
stock in GameStop as a joke,
and it caused so much chaos
that some C.E.O.s
want trading to be halted.
People can't keep their eyes off
the market right now.
You know what else people
can't keep their eyes off of?
"Bridgerton."
It's officially the most-watched
series in Netflix history,
with 82 million viewers.
The characters are high-society
Londoners, so fancy and proper.
They're kind of like people
who wouldn't be caught dead at
the new Margaritaville Resort
in Times Square.
It's coming later this year.
It has an outdoor pool,
rooftop views,
and a giant Statue of Liberty
holding a margarita.
If you ask me,
the whole thing seems nuts.
Yeah, there's
a Grape-Nuts shortage.
The company says
it's difficult to produce
the cereal right now, and
most stores are out of stock.
What's happening?
Are stocks going up, down?
It feels like Reddit
took a hammer to the market,
and now the
system's totally smashed.
And if you want to get
totally smashed, why not try
the Margaritaville Resort
in Times Square.
You probably shouldn't swim
with a bunch of drunk strangers,
but do your thing.
I'll be on my couch, sipping tea
and watching "Bridgerton."
It's a great show.
There's romance, scandal,
and, in that
classic British fashion,
the humor is really dry.
But not nearly as dry as
Grape-Nuts,
everyone's
favorite gravel-based cereal.
The company is suffering,
and that's why
we should all buy now.
Get it while it's low.
There can be as rich as everyone
on "Bridgerton."
In conclusion,
it's taking a hit.
It's full of Brits.
It's a spoonful of grit.
Elmo's about to get lit.
This has been a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Ding ]
Well, guys, as I mentioned,
Netflix just announced that
"Bridgerton" is its
most-watched new series ever.
Meanwhile, everyone who finally
learned how to play chess
is like, "Oh, come on."
Yep, the show's a hit.
The reviews call it
romantic, passionate,
and "something I regret
watching with my parents."
This is how popular the show is.
Today, I walked past
a construction site,
and one of the guys was like,
"Daphne's Empire-waist dress
in Episode 7 was
absolutely fascinating."
"Lou, no spoilers."
Yep, "Bridgerton" is Netflix's
most-watched series.
On the flip side,
they just announced their
least-watched series is...
I like that show.
I don't know.
Hey, like I was saying before,
later this spring,
Times Square is getting
a $300 million
Margaritaville Resort
with an outdoor pool.
Yeah, right now, the only way
to get a tropical escape
in the middle of Manhattan
is to stand over a subway grate.
Right now, the only way
to go to a pool
in the middle of New York City
is to head over to
Port Authority after it rains.
Some fashion news.
I saw that Louis Vuitton
recently unveiled
its fall 2021
menswear collection,
which includes
3-D skyline coats.
Take a look at these things.
-No.
-It's real.
Yeah, the coats actually
have a theme.
It's called
"No Sex in the City."
If you go to a coat check, they
don't even give you a ticket.
They go, "I'll remember."
You're in New York.
You came in dressed as
New York City. I know."
Yeah, they look like they're
background actors
in a school play.
It's like, "You didn't get
the lead, honey,
but you're just as important.
You're playing the set."
And, finally, a new lawsuit
out of California alleges that
Subway's tuna is
not actually tuna
and is really a mixture
of various concoctions.
Meanwhile, Blimpie is like,
"Shh, don't make eye contact.
No one will notice."
To be fair, Subway actually
does have real tuna,
but you have to order
the meatballs.